if you take a little take a look at the
list of the
top female billionaires the vast
majority of them had actually
acquired their wealth through divorce
yes they took half their husbands [ __ ]
and you know that just shows you the
power of divorce law
and you know it it increases over time
especially if you stay
married so that's why it's important to
get this information and get it out
there
and i'm i'm trying to get information to
younger guys because i know there's a
lot of older guys who know this because
they've been through it
they're like i've seen it i've been
married once it's not for me
oh it's a good refresher i mean there's
always older guys that are in their 40s
they're like hey rich you know i'm
thinking about you know getting an ltr
maybe living with her and getting
married again it's like dude
this is going to be number three sit
down shut up and pay attention for the
next hour
andrew's talking yeah and the thing is
guys you got to realize
living with her can be just as bad as
marriage i mean forget common law
there's
so much with cohabitation so much in
terms of economic risk
there's domestic violence risk because
if she's living with you
that counts as a domestic situation not
just as a
you know potential assault battery and
dv is dealt much more strictly
a lot of places there's mandatory
arrests which means if they the police
are called
they have to take somebody away or
they're strongly encouraged to
and it benefits the police to take them
away because then they're not liable
if the guy or girl whatever if there's
any violence afterwards
um some states have found the police
liable if they leave someone there
so they'll take somebody and nine times
out of ten is going to be the guy
unless there's like clear and convincing
evidence that the the woman did
something
it's gonna probably be the guy um so
just remember
guys when i'm talking about marriage
like it also applies to living with a
girl even if common law doesn't apply in
the state where you live
and as a note i have a whole video on
common law but it only applies in about
um eight jurisdictions in the united
states so the majority of
states don't follow common common law
marriage uh which
um quick definition is a type of
marriage
where you become married if you live
together and hold yourself out as
husband and wife for a certain period of
time
but that's in a minority of states
you